foreign
[Music]
top story
the super strength drug manufactured on
a Mexican Hillside now fueling an opioid
epidemic we'll have exclusive access to
an illegal fentanyl lab
the most important people in this whole
process are of course
the men who make the Phantom they call
themselves at the cooks the end of the
third protest it's pure thinking
also tonight tears in the witness box
the nurse accused of murdering seven
babies says it's sickening to be blamed
for their deaths
police carry out a controlled explosion
outside Buckingham Palace an arrest
demand found carrying a suspicious bag
a five percent pay rise for a million
NHS staff in England but doctors and
nurses could still go on strike Plus
a fairy tale ending players fans and
Hollywood owners celebrate wrexham's
return to the English Football League
we'll have a first look at tomorrow's
front pages too in our press preview
from 10 30.
[Music]
good evening it's a drug 50 times more
powerful than heroin which has become a
multi-million dollar business and
spawned a new wave in America's opioid
epidemic high up in the mountains of
northwest Mexico Sky News has witnessed
firsthand how one drawer cartel
manufactures super strength fentanyl
using chemicals smuggled from China
the Sinaloa cartel runs dozens of
illegal drug factories manufacturing
pure product transported one gang boss
tells us in all directions including to
the United States where in 2021 more
than at 70 600 people died of overdoses
involving synthetic opioids mostly
fentanyl that is 19 times higher than
the number of deaths in at 2013. now
fentanyl mostly is made in Mexico and is
trafficked directly into the United
States and then distributed worldwide
Sky News gained exclusive access to the
main trafficking gang and followed them
as they maze the drug and transported it
to the Mexican border from the city of
kualaikan in northwest Mexico our chief
correspondent Stuart Ramsey sent us this
from a small village on Mexico's Pacific
Coast fishing boats with powerful
engines speed through estuaries leading
to the ocean
it's early evening but they moved before
dark
on board are members of the Sinaloa drug
cartel one of the most powerful in
Mexico
they're heading to a rendezvous point to
pick up a shipment the cartel says has
been smuggled here from China
on an islet in water too shallow for
Mexico's Security Forces to use their
vessels a man helps load plastic Jerry
cans filled with chemicals known as
precursors
they are the crucial ingredients that
make the opioid drug Fentanyl
this is the first part of a process that
makes the cartel millions of dollars
but fuels an opioid epidemic that's
killing thousands of drug users in the
United States they move quickly Mexican
Marines are always near and drones are a
constant threat
they head to shore
the chemicals are loaded into a car to
be whisked away to a safe house
directions are given to us to join the
gang later that night
the back streets of culiacan the Sinaloa
cartel's headquarters are controlled by
Cartel gunmen
we'll watch constantly as we drive to
the Stash House
the precursors are already here
this is one of the cartel's most senior
players he's in charge of Distributing
the precursors to the fentanyl making
labs
this one Consignment he told me can make
half a ton of the drug
they do this every week
[Music]
defense labs are spread across the state
of Sinaloa in towns Villages and the
countryside
we're guided up a remote Hillside
hidden beneath trees and tarpaulin
sheets is a lab where the synthetic
opioid drug is made it's highly toxic
even breathing in the fumes here is
lethal
foreign
it's going to take a few hours to make
pure fentanyl the two gang members who
create the drug leave their guns on a
tree branch as they work through three
processes
essentially they're adding the Chinese
precursors acid and a variety of other
chemicals they won't reveal to us to
make a porridge-like mash that is then
re-diluted and mixed again
they have no qualms about making this
lethal cocktail
America's Americas that uh people like
yourself
are on a Wanted list because so many
people are dying in America
because of fentanyl do you care about
that
[Music]
each part of the process concludes with
a centrifuge removing the water as they
get nearer to the end
the most important people in this whole
process are of course
the men who make uh the Phantom they
call themselves the cooks and in fact
they they actually pay others to teach
them how to do it it's very much like a
professional chef they don't do it just
by time
they do it by how it looks what it feels
like if you like and that's how they
know when it's it's each process and
there's three processes that's when they
know that it's done of course at the end
of the third process it's pure sensing
there is a constant mixing stirring and
drying of the product in and out of
sheets and bags before they're finally
happy and indicate they're done they
never take off their gloves respirators
or aprons
pure fentanyl is emptied into a bowl
they break it into pieces
and move it into the sun to start drying
at another location the now dry fencing
is ground into powder in a smoothie
maker
the drug is carefully weighed into a
single kilo and loaded into a plastic
bag and then completely wrapped in thick
tape
this Consignment will join another batch
of kilo bags and is destined for the
United States
it's placed in a secret lot compartment
the cartel has installed in a pickup
the journey North now begins its
destination to Juana on the United
States border
once here the drugs are swapped into a
car with American number plates it then
joins the traffic that continuously
crosses between the two countries
in America dealers will cut the fentanyl
one kilo can quickly become 10 and the
profits multiply
if the demand is there this deadly trade
seems Unstoppable
well today after a global operation the
U.S Department of Justice said that 300
people were arrested for trafficking
drugs including 64 kilos of fentanyl on
the dark web now Stuart is in Tijuana
for us tonight and Stuart more than 150
those arrests were made in the US the
tentacles of the operation that you
witnessed spanning continents and
communities
yeah I think that's really the point
isn't it with cartels they're extremely
well organized in the past they've said
to me they can pretty much deliver
anything overnight certainly to the
United States but can go further afield
as well and you saw in that report they
were saying that they can get drugs
particularly fentanyl to the UK and to
Australia it is a huge Network obviously
it's headquartered in Mexico but it has
people and it has Partners who aren't
necessarily part of the cartel but part
of the crime Network and it is really
Global and I think what's interesting is
even though they make a lot of arrests
and some of those those are very high
profile the fact is that the cartels
continue to operate because another
leader takes over and the business just
goes on
okay Stuart thank you for that and
Stuart's reports is just the first in a
series of special reports this week that
we're calling fighting fentanyl now
earlier this year from the Streets of
Philadelphia we brought you the stories
of those who are addicted to the drug
here combined with an animal
tranquilizer the White House has
designated that cocktail which rots the
skin of those that use it as an emerging
threat to the nation
and then tomorrow we're in Texas where
we'll show you another devastating side
of the drug epidemic the impact on
school children and families
we lost our daughter Miley on February
17th of this year you don't believe it
could happen to you and here we are and
it truly could happen to anybody it was
at home
she had taken something during the night
and we found her the next morning
she had to she had passed away
to this day we don't know exactly what
she took we know that it was laced with
fentanyl
well join us at tomorrow for a special
program including eyewitness reporting
from Mexico and across the U.S border in
Texas and California that is fighting
fentanyl at seven o'clock tomorrow night
here on Sky News
now a nurse accused of killing seven
babies and attempting to murder 10
infants gave evidence in court for the
first time today and insisted that she
only did her best to care for them with
the parents of her alleged victims
looking on Lucy letby cried in the
witness box as she repeatedly denied
harming the young patients in her care
our national correspondent Tom parmint
over thoughts
it was the very youngest patients at the
Countess of Chester Hospital that Lucy
letby cared for
she treated each of the seven newborns
who died in suspicious circumstances
there in 2015 and 2016.
five years into her career as a nurse
Lucy leppy was accused of murder
she told the court I don't think you can
be accused of anything worse than that
my job was my life she broke down in
tears at this point and added my whole
world just stopped
in deciding to give evidence herself
Lucy letby has chosen to directly
confront the allegations that she
murdered babies in her care she was
asked seven times in a row whether or
not she'd harmed them
her defense team asked her have you ever
tried to kill any baby you've cared for
no have you ever intentionally harmed or
tried to intentionally harm any of the
babies as alleged
no never
have you ever introduced air
intravenously or forced air down a
nasogastric tube
no I haven't
have you done that for the intention of
killing a baby or for any other reason
no
her denials kept coming she said she'd
never assaulted babies never overfed
them and never poisoned them with
insulin
she described how upsetting it was when
a baby died on the unit to try and
process it she would often write down
notes
in one she wrote the words I killed them
on purpose because I'm not good enough
but Lucy letby said her mental state was
not good at all when she wrote it she
said it was just her processing her
thoughts she will continue to be
questioned on Friday and denies all the
charges she faces Tom Parmenter Sky News
Manchester
now police in London carried out a
controlled explosion outside Buckingham
Palace tonight and have arrested a man
on suspicion of possessing an offensive
weapon Ashner huronag is in central
London for his outside Buckingham Palace
and joins us now Ashner
it was around 7pm tonight Kamali in
which a man is understood to have
approached the gates of Buckingham
Palace behind me and thrown a number of
items onto the palace grounds those
suspicious items are believed to be
shotgun cartridges he was detained very
quickly by metropolitan police officers
who have been in the vicinity of
Buckingham Palace for days now and
consistently monitor the area he was
immediately arrested he was also found
to be in possession of a suspicious bag
say Scotland Yard a precautionary
controlled explosion on that bag was
then was then done by the Metropolitan
Police but there is an enormous
coordinate must be said around the
palace grounds behind me hence why it is
so quiet at the moment there are
military rehearsals going on through the
night but this incident understandably
has heightened tensions but it gives you
a sense of how uh I suppose immediate
the actions were of the police with how
important such an event is it's worth
saying that this is not being treated as
a terror offense and there have been no
injuries to officers or members of the
public reported but that man has indeed
been arrested on suspicion of possessing
an offensive weapon and he has been
taken and to custody
Ashner thank you for that now before the
incident the king and queen consort
visited parliaments to meet some
politicians ahead of Saturday's
coronation rehearsals are continuing
tonight in central London with thousands
of troops taking part our Royal
correspondent Laura bundock reports
time when a new monarch
Monarch coronation
today it's just handshakes and a cup of
tea the most here aren't invited on
Saturday I've got to say this was
amazing isn't it the king came to
Parliament and Parliament came out the
king and I'm going to say the sheer
numbers staff members of parliament
peers we were all here everybody who
wanted to be part of the coronation and
this was his gift to Paul up myself I
will Camille and he did the king in good
spirits with just days to go before his
coronation
but still plenty more preparation
especially for the Archbishop of
Canterbury who's leading the service and
will Crown the king I'm very conscious
of what a huge privilege it is to do it
and we've been doing lots of rehearsals
since February and you know it's slowly
coming together
also coming together visiting foreign
leaders as they're met by the king from
his own family a rare Insight with the
Princess Royal in interview discussing
the monarchy's relevance I think it's in
it perfectly true that it it is a moment
where you need to have that discussion
but I would just underline the that the
monarchy provides with the Constitution
a degree of long-term
stability
that it's actually quite hard to come by
any other way and as for slimming things
down well I think the slim Dan was was
said in a day when there were a few more
people around to make that seem like a
justifiable right a comment the world
changes a bit it changes a bit I mean it
doesn't sound like a good idea from
where I'm standing outside
Princess Anne has an honorary role at
the coronation procession
[Music]
and to that she'll be joined by
thousands of troops who are now making
their way into London Laura bundock Sky
News
now more than a million NHS staff in
England are going to receive a five
percent pay rise as soon as next month
the deal was signed off at a meeting
between the government and 14 Health
unions representing all NHS staff except
for doctors and dentists speaking
afterwards the health secretary Steve
Barclays said it was time to end the
strikes but doctors and nurses could
still walk out a health correspondent
Ashish Joshi explains why
after six months of picket lines and
hundreds of thousands of canceled
operations and appointments finally an
agreement on a pay deal for NHS workers
so I'm pleased that the majority of
Health unions that members accepted the
recommendations we made that it was the
it was the best alternative to waiting
for the pay review body process to run
out for this year the hope is that
lessons have been learned about the
value of of listening to NHS staff the
deal means more than a million NHS staff
will get a five percent increase and a
lump sum possibly as soon as June but
unions are divided unite and the Royal
College of Nursing will re-ballot
members like Mark over further strike
action I can't you know go to the
students who I train and say yeah I
think you're going to have a well-paid
profession a good career ahead of you
based on based on this pay deal and it
you know it would just make it was just
going to create more anger the way the
government have handled this imposing it
on people not not openly opening
negotiations it's just made people more
more angry and frustrated but the
government says the matter is now
settled this was a decision taken by 14
Health unions they reached a majority
decision it was negotiated collectively
at the RCN were at the negotiating table
indeed Pat Cullen recommended this deal
to her own members so it's important
that everyone now respects the decision
as
to the hell you
is now over there are some difficult
questions ahead for the RCN and unite
and the government will see this
breakthrough as proof that it can
negotiate a deal with the junior doctors
a pay deal reached but long-term issues
remaining including a record patient
waiting list and still no Workforce plan
to address the crisis in the Recruitment
and Retention of NHS staff
Ashish Joshi Sky News in central London
now for the first time in more than 40
years campaigners who say their babies
were harmed by the pregnancy drug
primidoso returned to the high court
over 100 claimants are looking to
rekindle their case against the drugs
manufacturers after their first attempt
collapsed in the early 1980s among them
the fiancee of one man who died before
getting his day in court our home editor
Jason Farrell as this
Jamie Hosmer was 12 when his parents
went to the high court claiming his
heart problems were caused by a drug his
mother took while pregnant
40 years later in November last year he
died of heart complications his parents
are dead too so his only representative
when the case returned to court today
was his fiancee last year yeah he passed
away on the 3rd of November and 100 I
believe it was because of primados he
would still be here the alarm about this
drug was first raised by scientist
Isabel gal in 1967 a research in nature
magazine suggested a higher number of
babies with spinal defects had been born
to women who used the pregnancy test
drug primidos but the drug remained on
the market for years until further
studies pointed to a link with other
abnormalities in the fetus and a warning
appeared on the packet in 1975 saying
primidos must not be taken unless it's
certain the patient is not pregnant we
we have been campaigning since 1978.
Mary Lyon a mother who used primados has
fought for decades for recognition that
hundreds of children were damaged by the
drug and in 2019 victims gave evidence
to a review
[Music]
[Applause]
dependent review concluded that primidos
had caused avoidable harm to people like
Nikki government Regulators failed to
act on warnings and it recommended
redress be paid to the victims I want to
issue a full apology to those who've
suffered and their families
but three years on the government's
legal team is side by side with that of
the manufacturer who told the court
today the claimants case is bound to
fail and therefore should be struck out
Matt Hancock you know how on Earth it
gets his face straight when he said it I
really don't know because it didn't mean
a word and that was quite apparent
because when we asked about it later on
the the answer was well we're actually
just apologizing because you've been
damaged but we didn't tax that
responsibility so what was that about so
what was that about well there is a
court case on that so it's important
that one allows the legal process to
follow its course so you will not expect
ministers to comment on issues that are
before the court
the manufacturer's sharing now owned by
Bayer say the legal challenge in 1982
failed and the science hasn't changed
since in 2017 an expert working group
found no new evidence of a causal
Association
they deny that their drug affected these
lives Jason Farrell's Sky News
now the president of FIFA is threatening
to stop a number of European countries
from watching this year's Women's World
Cup Gianni Infantino said that the
current offers from broadcasters for the
rights of the games were disappointing
and described them as a slap in the face
of all great players and all women
worldwide the World Cup is going to take
place in Australia in New Zealand in
seven weeks time with most games being
shown in the morning here in the UK
the government has announced it will run
additional evacuation flights tomorrow
for people looking to escape the
violence in Sudan people wanting to
leave have been told to arrive at Port
Sudan by 10 am in order to be processed
the past of a religious cult in Kenya
has been rearrested minutes after the
country's a lower court released him and
closed the case against him Paul
McKenzie is accused of inciting his
followers to starve to death in order to
meet Jesus officials say that the number
of deaths are linked to the cult has
risen to 110.
Hollywood writers closed their laptops
and headed to the picket lines today in
the first walkout for more than 15 years
it means that popular late night talk
shows could go dark maybe even tonight
as screenwriters demand fairer pay and
an assurance that their roles won't be
replaced by AI chat Bots IUS
correspondent James Matthews says this
[Applause]
is give it up for the band everybody
right there in screen entertainment it's
no laughing matter there's one big story
The Talk on the chat shows is the strike
of the scriptwriters these are our
Riders they're scriptwriters these
people without these people this show
would be called The Late Show with a guy
rambling about the Lord of the Rings and
boats for an hour
the people who write the material for
America's TV and film industry have
walked out in a pay dispute bringing a
halt to production
let us say that while streaming has
created more content and jobs they're
being paid less
and they're concern about Artificial
Intelligence being used to write scripts
in future
concerned about Ai and we all want to
live in a world where people have jobs
and if they hire Ai and do an AI
computer the ability to write a first
draft that's a writer losing a major
amount of their income writing a feature
film oh yeah I know it's the White House
no it's the capital here the
entertainment industry has learned
through experience the cost of strife
with its scriptwriters I brought you
as Leslie Knope is your guidebook I
didn't
it's not the first time the script's
been written America's writers went on
strike in 2007 it took programming off
the air and cost the California economy
more than two billion dollars is
successful he will be the oldest man
that's it just the oldest
just the oldest man TV chat shows that
rely on same day script writing are
already being canceled
they are the first screen casualties of
the writer's block they may not be the
last James Matthews Sky News in
Washington
well now to eight football fairy tale a
struggling Team new Hollywood buyers and
promotion to the English football league
today players and fans of rexham Bast in
their own success as they paraded their
trophy but if their owners would believe
this is just the first step on the road
the Premier League Chingy marike reports
this is what happens when Stardust meets
a passionate fan base who have waited 15
years to return to the football league
[Applause]
wrexham's promotion parade gave the
community a chance to celebrate their
Heroes
attacking the streets with streaks of
red and white
they're watching them years in
non-league you got all these good
players and bigger teams to take them
we've got a bigger budget now we can
keep the good players we've got to work
our way up slowly enjoy the process that
was unbelievable it's one of the best
experiences of my life wrexham all the
way through come on what these two guys
have done to this the team and the town
absolutely brilliant
2021 takeover by stars Ryan Reynolds and
Rob mcelhenney this team has found
investment and an international fan base
a story straight from a motion picture
the Hollywood owners were here today to
drink it all in
wrexham's Newfound success isn't just
about the team but the community around
the club it's brought International
attention to a local team in this corner
of North Wales
attention that has seen benefits for
local businesses Braxton doesn't stand
alone you know for towns that are you
know you know of economically struggled
in the last
decade or so you know austerities kicked
in in wrexham and parts and you know
it's it's been a bit of a struggle you
know but you know what this does do is
it brings people into the town it gets
people spending it gets businesses
earning a little bit more which creates
jobs and everybody knows enough and
effect on that
[Music]
[Applause]
they don't want to stop here the dream
is to one day compete in the Premier
League
that might seem far away but fans here
and around the world are hoping their
team's Hollywood Revival has only just
begun shinki marike Sky News
[Music]